Most people in the 18th century only had a
proper wash twice a year.
Finding Nemo, a movie about the suffering
of a captured clownfish, ironically caused
home aquarium demand for them to triple.
The first baseball gloves were flesh-coloured
in case spectators noticed and accused players
of cowardice.
Only a fifth of the Sahara desert is sand.
The rest consists of mainly gravel.
In 2007, a woman collapsed and lay on the
E.R floor of Martin Luther King Jr.-Harbor
Hospital in Los Angeles for 45 minutes as
hospital staff ignored her.
A janitor mopped the floor around her as she
vomited blood.
She was then arrested by police for causing
a disturbance and died on the stretcher.
Take-out restaurants existed in ancient Rome,
with service counters opening onto the street
to pick up food.
More than 200 existed in Pompeii, and most
of its homes lacked dining or kitchen areas,
suggesting that cooking at home was unusual.
To improve their ability to swallow hot dogs,
the International Federation of Competitive
Eating is studying black holes.
As a boy, Roald Dahl taste-tested new chocolate
bars for Cadbury's.
80% of all food has sugar added to it.
It would cost the US government less money
to provide homes to the homeless than it does
to leave them on the street.
It is as difficult for a bacterium to swim
through water as it is for a human to swim
through syrup.
The first Atomic bomb dropped on Japan was
assembled while the aircraft was actually
in flight.
This was done to avoid detonation while taking
off because bombers kept crashing and burning
on the runway.
It took them 25 minutes to assemble the weapon
while in flight.
As a nuclear safety inspector, Homer Simpson
earns $20,000 more than the average American.
In the 19th century, circumcision was used
to treat epilepsy, hernias, lunacy and paralysis.
The last film rented out by Blockbuster was
the 2013 comedy This Is the End.